foreign
[Music]
my name is David McGuire I'm a data
scientist at dvo1 we are a fintech
startup and we provide analytics for
investors in fixed income
so something that I've heard a few times
over my career is that R is bad for
production sometimes Engineers say oh
this is this looks great but uh let's
put in another language for production
they say R is ad hoc it's for analysis
there's no package management
but today I want to dispel some of those
Notions and I want to show you that R is
great for production
so first I'd like to talk a little bit
about uh what I work on so I work on
tape cracker which is a web application
that has a few components there's a
JavaScript front end there's a Scala
back end and then we have a machine
learning microservice in R which
provides predictions that are used by
the two other components of the
application and this application is used
live by customers they can get on at any
time they expect the results immediately
so um there's there's very high
requirements for availability and
dependability our sales team demos this
app live to clients to prospective
clients so it has to work every time if
there's a failure we could lose a
prospective client so
um
this machine learning microservice has
to be very robustly engineered satisfy
uh what our customers expect of us
so I'm going to tell you how can you
raise an R microservice to thrive in the
wild
so here we have our our microservice
this cute little draft
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to put our R micro
microservice through school we're going
to teach it what to do once we release
it out into the wild
the end result of that is that once we
release it into the wild it can interact
with other microservices other
applications written in different
languages seamlessly and just have a fun
time
so let's talk a little bit more
concretely what is an R microservice so
it's basically our code behind plumber
in Docker so we take our R code our
machine learning model and we put it
behind a plumber API this allows any
other application to hit our machine
learning model and it only has to
provide the expected input and it gets
an output so any other service doesn't
need to know anything about the r
language
and then we wrap around that
um plumber API we put it in a Docker
package this makes our API portable so
once it's in a Docker package or a
Docker image we can deploy it into the
cloud on in a variety of destination
so
a little bit more concretely in in our
circumstance at dvo1 the microservice
wild this is our web application this is
what it looks like it provides a lot of
information that investors need to make
decisions
um and we have a JavaScript front end we
have uh Scala back end and then behind
that even we have a data engineering
pipeline in Scala and we have our r
machine learning microservice sits on
top of that and is able to provide
results to each of the components in
that pipeline
so this is this is a this is a great
setup for a data scientist because I can
focus on what I'm good at which is
building models and building data
science projects and then the software
Engineers that I work with they can
build the end-to-end system so
very convenient
so in in pursuit of building robust art
deployments I want to introduce three
devops principles the first is
continuous integration and that's where
we build and test our our packages the
second is continuous deployment this is
where we take our tested packages and
release them into production systems and
then the third is uh cluster Computing
which is a common destination in for um
applications in production in the cloud
so let's start with continuous
integration
this is a simple continuous integration
workflow so we start at the top left
where a data scientist is working in our
in our studio making updates to the
model making updates to the code so
whenever a data scientist makes an
update the code base they will push that
to a version tracking tool such as
GitHub at that point the application
will be built from the source code
and then we're going to run automated
tests on that and this this happens
automatically once I push all that
happens and then I'll get a report back
if the tests fail I know I have to go
back and fix something if they test pass
I can then progress
um I can merge my changes into the
master brand and then we will have a
application that is ready for deployment
so let's look a little bit closer into
this first part of the CI pipeline
so it this is this in the CI build step
basically we have a data scientist is
working in our studio writing our code
and we're gonna get push and that's
going to trigger GitHub actions to kick
off the continuous integration pipeline
there's many options for CI tools we use
GitHub actions at dvo1 and then the
GitHub actions is going to build a
Docker image based on the updated code
and what's important here is that
I'm pushing my code frequently that
means that I can get instant feedback on
what each piece of code that I edit and
so I know where changes happen if I push
500 lines of code at once and something
fails it's going to take me a long time
to figure out what goes wrong but if I
push a couple lines at a time I can
isolate the problems very easily
so now let's look at this next step
we're running the automated tests
So within continuous integration tests
we have three broad categories of tests
um sort of there's this pyramid
structure so the base our unit tests
these are the most numerous pests that
we have above those we have integration
tests which are still a good amount of
those but less than unit tests and
finally there are end-to-end tests and
the test that package is very useful for
writing these type of tests
so starting at unit tests this is the
base of our testing pyramid and the goal
here is to test functions individual
lines of code
um and really look at each component of
your r package so here I have a trivial
example of a unit test where I did I
Define this add 20 function and then I
use test that to assert that if I add 20
to 10 it should equal 30. and I Define
this and this is going to run every time
I push updates to my package so if I
were to make any changes to this
function that would break it I would get
immediate feedback and these type of
tests are
um
something that you should have a lot of
um for example
um it's a it's a really good idea to
create unit tests for your features to
make sure that all the features that go
into your models have have tests and are
never break or never give unexpected
input
um if you're imputing missing values at
prediction time that would be a good
thing to a unit test you could also test
like data structures like make sure that
functions return
data frames of expected structures and
things like that so writing a lot of
these unit tests allows you to make sure
that your code doesn't break in
unexpected ways and it helps you
identify failures
so the next level is integration test so
for integration tests the goal is to
make sure that our our microservice can
interact with other services that it
will need to so
um we may be interacting with databases
or apis so we're going to write tests to
make sure
um that our our container can interact
with every service it needs
and finally there are end-to-end tests
and this is where we're looking at the
whole microservices application as a
whole so this is in our case is looking
at our whole web app it doesn't really
tell us much about our our microservice
but it's necessary to have a holistic
view of everything where we actually get
useful input about our our package are
the two previous categories of path
now when we're writing tests we want to
write them at the right time
if you start writing tests too early you
can waste a lot of time but they save a
lot of time and product so if you start
a new project when you're in the
exploratory phase doing Eda initial
experiments if you start writing a lot
of tests you're going to slow yourself
down but as you progress as you get your
feature set more concrete as you get
closer to production you should start
introducing first unit tests later
integration tests and once you're really
close to production to releasing a
microservice you're going to want to
make sure that the end-to-end tests are
properly configured in
so next we're going to talk about
continuous deployment so at the end of
The Continuous integration pipeline we
have our container that's ready for
deployment
and what is going to happen here is that
this pipeline is going to take that
container and it's going to push it
through our different environment here
at dvo1 we have a staging release and
productive environment there's many ways
to do continuous deployment this is just
one example so once the container is
ready it's going to be pushed to staging
and in staging there will be some
end-to-end tests that run and we'll just
make sure that the whole application
looks good as a whole that if that goes
well it moves on to release and then
finally it'll go to production and and
this is important because
we have a customer facing application
and we have zero tolerance for any
failures or for downtime so we really
need to make sure that we have a lot of
steps in place to catch any errors uh
that might come up
and each of these environments the
staging release in production is a full
replica of the product environment you
it has our web application it has the r
microservice as well as all the other
services that make up the application
so let's talk a little bit the last
concept which is
um cluster Computing so in the cloud a
common way to run jobs is in kubernetes
so here we have our production cluster
in which we have three replicas of our
machine learning application so it's
important that we don't just we're not
just running it once we're running it
several times it that we have redundancy
so when another microservice comes along
and says hey R give me some predictions
it's going to first go to load balancer
the load balancer is going to look at
all the replicas of our our machine
learning microservice and it's going to
Route it the one that is free and that
is error free
and then the our microservice will
respond back and then the the full
microservice application can continue
doing its work
and so what's important here as I
mentioned this is a replica set so in
kubernetes
um you have replica sets which basically
says that for this application you're
going to have
um always going to have three instances
of this application in this case
um and if one of the Apple if one of the
replicas goes bad it will be torn down
and a new one will spun up immediately
if we're getting high traffic
we can route new traffic to a free
um replica of our microservice
so it's very important it gives us a
redundancy and it allows us to handle
High request loads this also allows
scaling
so in conclusion I just want to show
that R is great for production with um
proper CI and CD practices continuous
integration up to build and vet your R
practices continuous deployment helps
you release update seamlessly plumber
is an important component for a
microservice because it packages uh your
R code behind an API where any service
that has no knowledge of R can get
results from your R code
and then doctor creates these portable
software packages that you can run on
your laptop you can run in the cloud and
then kubernetes is essentially Orchestra
orchestration engine that will take
those dockerized your doctorized
application and run it in the cloud it
helps you maintain redundancy
um it has health check to help make sure
that your application doesn't
and
yep thank you and uh anyone has some
questions I'd be happy to take them
foreign
[Music]